what is the difference between sabr and shakwa what is translated as patience and complaining
one
of the things to keep in mind is that the concept and the idea of patience
and the word patience itself is not the greatest translation for summer in the Arabic language
why because Soviet as we know it is to refrain or detain or stop something from
happening in the religious context it's to hold oneself back from something that is detrimental so
during times of hardship for example you are holding yourself back and refraining from saying or
doing that which is displeasing to Allah as for complaining there are two different types of
complaints there is complaining to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and the example that we have is
from the Quran nama
ash kuba 'they were hosni in allah yahoo bali he said i'm said i complained of
my grief and my hardship to allah subhanho wa taala so
you are asking upon allah subhanaw taala are you allowed to say oh Allah I call
upon you and I am weak and I'm complaining to you of my weakness it is
permissible based on some authentic narrations as well and Allah knows best but with regards to
the second type it is complaining about our problems our decrees our issues to other people
where are the guidelines here we want to be consistent with our gratitude to Allah but
at the same time we realize yes
it is permissible to go ask for advice from other people it is permissible to speak
about our problems but not in a way in which we are complaining about our fate
our blessings and so on and so forth rather in terms of seeking advice from those
who have experience or those who can relate or those who can advise us and be
there for us but generally speaking we complain of our problems to allah subhana wa ta'ala
asking
him with our weakness for help because he is on lawsuit on Owatonna the exalted and
allah knows best